China has a long tradition of linguistics.
Do you know that Chinese scholars have long studied the pronunciation of ancient languages?
It has been several centuries ahead of the Europeans' formation of the ancestral language.
This video will tell the story of the Chinese revealing the ancient imperial language.
The pronunciation of Chinese has always caused me a headache.
It started on the day when Grandpa gave me a dictionary and several tapes as a birthday present.
But recently, I have delved into hundreds of pages in Chinese history.
Do you know what I found? I am not alone.
Many Chinese scholars are also deeply confused about the pronunciation of Chinese, and this history is quite long.
For example, this buddy.
The scholar began to construct language in the 1840s.
I have already told the story of constructing a language: Compare a set of languages,
Divided into a language tree,
Finally, construct their common ancestors.
However, this story is a bit different. This scholar's name is Chen Hao.
He is faced with a historical problem that has not been solved for hundreds of years:
How do you let the classic literature read its original sound?
How to let the poems written by the ancients rhyme again?
The problem is: you don't have a recording,
No phonetic symbols,
Not even ABC.
The object you want to deal with is the "word", which is the "Chinese character" we discussed earlier.
Each word represents a monosyllabic word or word formation component.
Chen Yu looked at the book in front of him. This book has been around for a long time, and it is even dull.
But the story behind it is quite exciting.
Before 1261, a Mr. Lu (Lu Fayan) invited eight friends to gather together overnight.
They have a wine companion and talk about it.
Late at night, the friendly chat ended and a fierce debate began.
The subject of the debate is the precise pronunciation of ancient documents.
"The reading of the northerners is wrong!" "No, the talents of the South are wrong!"
"Don't make a noise!" Lu Fayan dampened his brush.
I wrote an outline for the later "Chang Yun".
The book is finally divided into five volumes.
11,000 Chinese characters are classified into four tones.
Subdivided into different rhymes.
Then he splits the pronunciation of each Chinese character.
How to dismantle it? Also find two Chinese characters!
The upper word indicates the initial,
The lower word indicates the finals including the tones.
Take a word for example, it means "Oriental."
Its initial is indicated by "de" / tək̚ /, and the final is indicated by "red" / ɦuŋ /.
According to the pronunciation of the scholar, it reads /tuŋ/. We will discuss the constructed ancient sounds at the end.
With this method called "reverse cut", you can get a syllable reading!
It's really easy to understand, full of wisdom!
But it can't describe the overall appearance of the Chinese phonology.
In order to solve this problem, the poets need to go further:
Arrange such information into a rhyme.
The book "Rhythm Mirror" written in the 12th century contains many such rhymes.
What appears on the screen is the first rhyme in The Mirror.
The first label gives the serial number of the rhyme: First.
And the finals of Chinese characters: /uŋ/.
The top row is the six pronunciation parts of the consonant.
Below are four tones.
Each tone is divided into four "etc.", and "etc." contains more syllable information.
However, the interpretation of "equal" is still controversial.
Try it out: Help me find an initial that belongs to the "tongue", that is, the tongue of the modern linguistics.
"Clear", that is, clear consonants,
The word that belongs to the first tone.
We got a syllable like this: "East" / tuŋ/.
Next to it is a word that belongs to "Second Clear", which is the aspirate consonant, which is "pass" /thuŋ/.
"Cloudy" means "dirty" or "muddy", which means a voiced consonant,
Then we get the same "/" / ŋ /.
well! So what are these circles?
What do they mean?
"There is no such syllable."
So, if you are looking for a "clear" "lip" that belongs to the first tone,
You will find that there is no record such as /puŋ/ in this book.
However, there is "Peng" / buŋ /, which means "Peng Cao".
In this way, you have unearthed the ancient pronunciation, which is the rhyming method of Chinese.
For centuries, confident scholars have used this method to read the pronunciation of ancient Chinese syllables.
There are 36 initials in the education of Chinese.
But Chen Hao does not believe this conclusion.
He combed the ancient reverse cut,
Carefully tie the initials and initials, finals and finals.
There are several problems with the ties.
The number of initials in Chinese is not 36, but 41.
There are 5 initials to be separated.
The problem is not limited to this: The word sound in the rhyme picture is different from the "cut rhyme".
This is two different stages of Chinese.
Subsequent research will prove that the early nature of (cut rhyme) is already very complicated.
It is a hodgepodge of several ancient Chinese pronunciations. * * This view is still debated in the academic world.
Recall the argument they had about the South and the North on that night.
This seems to be true.
But after Chen Hao’s efforts, we only got many categories. Different boxes.
Tone box.
The initials box.
The box of the finals.
I can't stand guessing and guessing.
What exactly is the actual pronunciation of these boxes?
At the beginning of the 20th century, a Swede traveled to China to study these ancient rhymes and rhymes.
Then add the most important piece to this puzzle: the various Chinese dialects that have been passed down to the present.
Gao Benhan is obsessed with this.
He designed the survey plan and went to various places to record dialects.
With the results of the survey, different rhymes are filled with real pronunciations.
How did he do that? Let's use the fourth tone, which is called "into the sound".
In the coastal areas of southern China, the sound word has a stop.
For example, this ancient Chinese character means "country".
It is pronounced /kuo˧˥/ in Mandarin, but Cantonese is pronounced /kwok̚˧/.
Which dialect is more ancient?
Let's take a look at the list of "Dialects" listed by Gao Benhan, the last three languages: Korean, Japanese, and Vietnamese.
These three languages ​​use "out-of-domain sounds".
Basically, when Chinese characters borrow these languages, the pronunciations that these people think are.
Among the three languages, the word "country" also has the "k" at the end.
The evidence all points to the ancient pronunciation of the word "country" ending in consonants, /kwək̚˧/.
Linguists continue to perfect the structure of speech and depict the voice of ancient Chinese.
Although such pronunciation is like a foreign language in today's Mandarin.
They even revealed some important differences that Gao Benhan did not notice, such as "heavy bonds."
They also let me learn the Chinese pronunciation in this effort, and learned another thing:
This is not a single language called "Ancient Chinese."
No, this is a period in the history of language called "Chinese Middle Ages."
"Middle Ages"...because there is a more ancient language waiting to be discovered,
It is still a thousand years older than "Chinese for Middle Ages".
Maybe one day, we can understand the rhyming way of ancient Chinese.
Before the day arrives, please come to this channel and keep on subscribing to keep the subscription.